ام
اهلا بكم تسود حاله من التوتر العاصمه
اليمنيه رغم الاعلان عن سيريال اتفاق جديد
لوقف القتال بين الحرس الرئاسي ومسلحين
جماعه الحوثي وكانت وزيره الاعلام قد وصفت
اشتباكات صنعاء بانها محاوله انقلاب نتوقف
مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
ماذا بقي للرئيس اليمني من سلطه بعد هذه
التطورات الميدانيه
وما هي العوامل عوامل صمود اتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار بين الحوثيين والحرس الرئاسيه
احدث المتسارعه في اليمن تشي بعوده
الاوضاع الامنيه والسياسيه الى مربعها
الاول بين جماعه الحوثي والرئاسه اليمنيه
الحوثيون يتمددون ويحكمون و يحكمون قبضتهم
على العاصمه صنعاء احداث دفعت وزير
الاعلام في الحكومه اليمنيه الى وصف ما
جرى اليوم بمحاوله انقلاب وان ما يبثه
التلفزيون الرسمي او تنشره وكاله الانباء
الرسميه لا يعبر عن الحكومه في الاشاره
الى خضوعهما لسيطره الحوثيين حسب تعبيرها
تقرير احمد الشلفي
لا جديد في المشهد عمليا فالحوثيون احكام
القبضه على صنعاء في الواحد والعشرين من
سبتمبر من العام الماضي والرئيس اليمني
عبد ربه منصور هادي خضع الامر الواقع وبدا
بتعيينهم في المراكز السياديه والعسكريه
الهامه وبينهما النظام الامني العميق
للرئيس المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح الذي ظل
يقدم الدعم الاستخباراتي والميداني
الحوثيين وينكر ذلك عبر وسائل الاعلام
خشيه غضب السعوديه التي عبرت اكثر من مره
عن كشف هالحقيقه ذلك
والحقيقه ال ماثله للعيان منذ سيطره
الحوثيين على صنعاء ومحافظات شمال وغرب
البلاد سيطره كامله تقول انهم باتوا
الوحيدين في البلاد الذين يملكون قوه
عسكريه قادره على حسم الموقف وست تواطؤ من
محسوبين عليهم وعلى الرئيس المخلوع لصالح
في الامن والجيش
هذه الدوله الاداري لكن التحركات الاخيره
في العاصمه اليمنيه بدءا من اختطاف مدير
مكتب الرئيس الدكتور احمد عوض بن مبارك من
قبل الحوثيين تقول ان خلافات نشبت بين
الرئيس هادي والحوثيين تمثلت في انسحابهم
مع حزب المؤتمر الشعبي من اجتماعات الهيئه
الوطنيه وانسحاب صالح الصماد مستشار
الرئيس عن الحوثيين من لجنه المستشارين
وتقول المعلومات ان اللجان الشعبيه للحوثي
حسبت خلال الايام الماضيه امر السيطره على
بقيه المؤسسات التي ليست في يدها القصر
الرئاسي و مقر جهاز الامن القومي و جهاز
الامن السياسي
والذهاب ابعد من ذلك في تحديد مصير الرئيس
هادي
ويبدو ان الصمت المريب والنفي السريع من
الرئيس المخلوع لصالح لمشاركته في اقتحام
القصر الرئاسي والاشتباكات بين الحوثيين
وقوات الحمايه الرئاسيه كلها تفتح الباب
امام بروز خطه مشتركه بين مسلحي الحوثي
وقوات صالح القبليه او تلك التي تؤيده في
الجيش للدفع باتجاه تشكيل مجلس عسكري
الرئاسي او انتقالي يكون صالح جزء منه عبر
مرشحين متفق عليها مع جماعه الحوثي
والارجح ان تصريحات سابقه صدرت عن القيادي
ياسر العواضي المقرب من صالح بعد سقوط
صنعاء في سبتمبر الماضي تتحدث عن خطه
بديله مشتركه لاسقاط الرئيس هادي الذي
يعتبره جناح صالح في المؤتمر الشعبي العام
خصما تصدق نفسها في هذه اللحظه والسؤال
الان اذا ما حسمت فرضيه الخلاص من الرئيس
اليمني منهم اللاعبون الرئيسيون الى جانب
الحوثي في هذه العمليه وهل سيستمر الحوثي
متحكما امس يحكم فعلا ويسيطر على الرئاسه
كل شيء في اليمن يسير باتجاه نهايه واحده
يحسمها من يملك السلاح على الارض ولا
سيناريو اخر
لمتابعه هذا الوضع ينضم الينا من بيروت
الناشط السياسي اليمني عبد الحافظ معجب
ومن اسطنبول المحلل السياسي ياسين التميمي
ومن صنعه عبر الهاتف الدكتور رياض يسير
وزير الصحه اليمني اهلا بضيوفي الكرام
وابدا بضيفي اسطنبول المحلل السياسي ياسين
التميمي
ما الذي يجري في صنعاء هذا اليوم وماذا عن
ما نقل عن وجه الانسان عارض وما قد تصبح
غدا على غير ما امست عليه هذا اليوم او في
الايام الماضيه
مساء الخير ما حدث في صنعاء هو استكمال
لحلقه
الانقلاب الذي بدا الحوثيون في يناير من
العام
الماضي وكان بمسانده الرئيس اليمني نفسه
والسفاره الامريكيه والرعاه الدوليون اه
واليوم هي الحلقه الاخيره في تقديري اعتقد
عندما اقتحم الحوثيون اذار الرئاسه هذا
اليوم
فهذا يعني ان نفس السيناريو يتكرر كتائب
عسكريه كانت مكلفه في الحمايه انسحبت
القتال كان محدودا على ما يبدو اه ما احدث
سلسله من الخيانات ادت الى تسليم واساس
الدوله بكاملها الى الجماعه الحوثيه
المسلحه اعتقد ان ما حدث هو جهد عسكري
مشترك نخبه او بمعظمه
موالون للرئيس السابق الرئيس المخلوع علي
عبد الله صالح الحوثيون لا زالوا في
الواجهه اكثر مما
قوات عسكريه مقاتله في الميدان منفرده
بالسيطره وبحسب الامور العسكريه
معركه السيطره على اه دار الرئاسه كشفت
الى اي مدى تورط النظام السابق في عمليه
هدم الدوله واه اه القيام بالثوره المضاده
ونجاحه في تحقيق كل ذلك خلال الفتره
الماضيه
فقط لان
سيد سيد ياسين لان الوضع دقيق جدا في
العاصمه صنعاء في هذه اللحظات وال الوضع
يختلف بين ساعه اخرى للوقوف على مجريات
الوضع وما يجري في هذه اللحظات معنا عبر
الهاتف الدكتور رياض ياسين وزير الصحه
اليمني دكتور رياض ماذا عن الجديد ماذا عن
الوضع حتى الان
اه الوضع طبعا في الوقت الحاضر هناك هدوء
نسبي مؤقت
لكن تم حصر اه ما استطعنا من عدد المصابين
التوصل الى حوالي
واكثر من خمسطاشر من القتله اه للاسف
الشديد اه كانت هناك بعض للشوارع لا
نستطيع الوصول اليها الانقاذ
المصابين والقتله في هذه المساله اه
الجاره يبدو ان طبعا المحاوله الانقلابيه
اه بالتخفيض غير المرور بالطريقه الصالحيه
اه ما يدور اليوم في داخل صنعاء اه ان ارض
ال اه
المعرفه كما يقال هي اه في امام الاماكن
السياسيه اه سواء كان الرئاسه او القصر
الجمهوريه ما شابه ذلك اه واضح ان هناك
تعمد من قبل اه اه الحوثيين اه في اقتحام
هذه الاماكن اه اما اجراءاتهم الاخرى غير
مقبوله على الاطلاق تصفون
الدكتور تصفون ما جرى بانه محاوله
انقلابيه ما الذي افشل ها او فشلها على
حتى الان على الاقل
اه الذي هو الصمود الشعب اليمنيون تفاهمه
اه القياده الشرعيه الرئيس عبد الله
المنصور هذه اه الذي يفشل ايضا اه الوعي
الجمعي الذي تشكل من خلال مؤتمر الحوار
الوطني واه وما وما ترتب على ذلك بان الان
اه اذا كان هناك اي مشاركه اه بعد اتفاق
السن والشركات يجب ان تكون تحت اطار
السلم والتفاهم اه وليس فرض القوه ولا
الدراع واستخدام هذا الاتهام وجه
الرياضه ال المسؤولين هذه الاتهامات
الحوثيين
اه بالتاكيد ما يدور الان من معارك حول اه
اماكن سياسيه ليست المعركه في صعده ولا في
اماكن اخرى حتى يت ظلم اه من تظلم ويعتقد
انه تم الهجوم عليه
العموم يتم على الاماكن السياسيه ومن حق
القوات الرئاسيه الدفاع عن هذه الاماكن
ضيفي من بيروت السيد عبد الحافظ
في هذه العمليات هو راس الرئيس هذه او
كرسيه الرئيسه هذه
اسمح لي في البدايه انا اود ان اضحك كثيرا
من يتحدث عن الانقلاب هم الانقلابيون
هؤلاء الذين انقلبوا على اتفاق السلم
والشراكه وانقلبوا على كل الاتفاقيات
المبرمه
وانقلبوا ايضا على مخرجات مؤتمر الحوار
الوطني ما يحدث اليوم هي ثوره شعبيه
واستكمال لثوره فبراير واستكمال ثوره واحد
وعشرين سبتمبر ما يحصل اليوم هي تحرك شعبي
ثوري اليوم من يتحرك في العاصمه صنعاء
ليسوا انصار الله الحوثيين هذه مغالطات
كبيره عندما تتحدث وزيره الاعلام ويتحدث
معالي وزير الصحه ان العيون يريد ان
ينقلبوا على السلطه الحقيقه ان انصار الله
يقف اليوم حجر عثره امام اللجان الثوريه
واللجان الشعبيه
بمبادره
مباشره
اولا يسمى ما يجري ما الهدف من العمليات
العسكريه هل هو ازاحه الرئيس هذه من كرسي
الرئاسه
هو استكمال للثوره الشعبيه التي وقفت
المؤسسه الرئاسيه في بغض النظر عن التوصيف
بان توصيف يعني نقول لك كما هو الهدف منها
ازاحه الرئيس هادي من كرسي الرئاسه بشكل
مباشر
الى حتى اللحظه لا لا يوجد قرار مثل هذا
بازاحه الرئيس مباشره او بازاحه الرئيس من
من كرسي الرئاسه وما هو القرار لا زالت
هناك جهود ومساعي نعم لا زالت ومساعي لان
يعدل الرئيس عن قرار السته الاقاليم
المفروض من الخارج وهناك جهود ومسائل وما
حصل اليوم اذا اردتم توصيف حقيقي لما حصل
اليوم كما حصل منذ الصباح الباكر بان
الرئيس عبد ربه منصور هادي هو من وجه
المؤسسه الامنيه والعسكريه بالاعتداء على
المواطنين والقصف بالمدفعيه على مساكن
المواطنين في المناطق القريبه من دار
الرئاسه
الرد على هذا الانتشار العسكري الحوثيين
كان يوحي بان الامر مدبر وليس رد فعل على
اي عمل امن كما ذكرته قبل قليل اذن
المساله مدبره واهدافها
كما يقول خصوم الحوثيين
التحرك العسكري بدا من يوم امس كان هناك
انتشار عسكري غريب في مناطق مختلفه من
العاصمه صنعاء كان هناك تواصل العقلاء تم
التواصل بالرئاسه انه لا نريد ان يذهب
البلد الى صراع مسلح من جديد نريد ان نغلب
المصلحه الوطنيه العليا نريد فخامه الرئيس
عبد ربه منصور هادي ان يتراجع عن التهور
بالزج بالمؤسسه الامنيه والعسكريه في
الصراع مع اللجان الثوريه واللجان الشعبيه
ولكنه لم يعقل وزج بهم في الصراع ترددت
الكثير من القيادات الامنيه والعسكريه من
المشاركه فيه واليوم تطور الامر وقد تصل
اللجان الثوريه الى القصر الجمهوري وقد
يكون هناك اعلان لمجلس الرئاسه خلال
الساعات القادمه من يدري اذا استمر الرئيس
بعناده ويريد ان يستمر بالوصايه الخارجيه
على البلد اذا استمر الرئيس عبد الله واد
ان يستقوي بالدول التي تتصور له الوضع
بانه هو الرئيس الشرعي عبد ربه منصور هادي
الحقيقه ذكرته في كلام السيد
ضيفي من من صنعاء دكتور رياض ياسين الحديث
عن مرحله انتقاليه عن مجلس رئاسي هل هو
تاكيد لمخاوف كما م مجرد تصريحات صحفيه لم
تنقل عن ناس مسؤولين بشكل مباشر اه هو
الذي ان القانون
وادى سلفا اه في احداث انقلاب اه على اه
كل مخرجات الحوار الوطني والذي شارك فيه
اه الاخوان صار الله اه شاركوا في اه
سطاشر شاركوا في كل ال المحاور اه ثم وقع
الاتفاق السلم والشراكه اه ما يتكلم به
الاخ من بيروت اه هو يدل على هذا الحماس
منقطع
النظير اه في انه طلب الامور
ولذلك اه اعتقد اه
يعني في الاخير جنت على نفسها براقش ما
يقول هو يقول انه لا توجد حركه انقلابيه
ويتكلم عن انه سيكون من السياسي ونحن في
انتظار اه البيان الاول اه كما يقول الاخ
اه ال المساله الان واضحه اه هناك استهداف
واضح من قبل النظام السابق اه ومن قبل
المكونات السابقه اه بالتحالف مع
الحوثيين للانقلاب على كل الانجازات
اليمنيين مشعل الحوار اشكرك والدكتور رياض
وعشرين وزير الصحه اللي كنت معنا من
العاصمه صنعاء ضيفي من اسطنبول الاستاذ
ياسين التميمي قبل قليل اشرت باصابع
الاتهام الى الرئيس هادي وحمله المسؤوليه
وقلت بان هذا العمل كان مدبرا من قبل وان
الرئيس يتحمل جزء من المسؤوليه لماذا
تحميل الرئيس هادي والوضع في اليمن معروف
لا مؤسسات قائمه لا مؤسسه الجيش ولا اي
مؤسسه رسميه في البلد قائمه اذن لماذا
اتهام الرئيس واليوم يعاني ما يعاني في ظل
وضعه الحالي
اقول لان الرئيس يتحمل جزء كبير من
المسؤوليه لانه تخلى عن امانه المسؤوليه
وقبل بان اه تقع مؤسسه الرئاسه اه في ظل
هذا النوع من ال من المهانه
يتذكرون في يناير من البدايه 2014 عندما
اه بدات حركه الحوثيين في صعده بمحاصره
تواطا مع الحوثيين من الولايات المتحده من
السفير الامريكي ثم بدات المعركه ولم
تنتهي التي صنعها كل واحد وعشرين سبتمبر
كانت هذه المؤامره شارك فيها الرئيس هذه
بكل وضوح اذا اليوم الامور تمشيط باتجاه
مغاير الذين الذين شاركوا في اسقاط صنعاء
يعبرون عن تيار مختلف تماما انهم يتجهوا
الى تاسيس دوله
تتوجه طائفي مناطق انهم يسعون بكل ما
لديهم من قوه لتوجيه المعركه باتجاه
الاستئثار بالسلطه على اساس مناطق وهذا
بالتاكيد على حساب وحده اليمن وامنه
واستقراره
لم يعد امام الرئيس عبد ربه منصور هادي من
اي خيارات واعتقد ان هم الذين حاصروا ذري
الرئاسه واقتحم هذا اليوم ارادوا الخيارات
امام الرئيس هادي بحيث
يدفعوا من تلقاء نفسه للتخلي عن السلطه
وهنا يدفعون بمقترح هم هذا الذي يريده
الاخ من بيروت وبعض الناشطين الحوثيين وهو
تشكيل مجلس عسكري اذا هم لا يريدون ان
نظهر للعالم بانهم انقلبوا على عبد ربو من
السلطه ووجه اليه الا هم ياخذوا عليه دار
الرئاسه والقصر الجمهوري ويحاصر في منزله
ثم لم يكن امامهم
الاستقاله
الانسان ضيفنا من صنعاء راجح بادي الناطق
باسم رئيس الوزراء اليمني للحديث عن
محاصره اه الرئيس عبد ربه منصور هادي وعن
الوضع حاليا في العاصمه صنعاء درجه
اه اخي الكريم اه الان
ما يسمى باللجان الشعبيه تحاصر القصر
الجمهوري اه
بصنعاء وهو مقر شكل دوله رئيس الوزراء
الاستاذ خالد بحاح رئيس حكومه الكفاءات
منذ اه تم تكليفه بتشكيل هذه الحكومه وهو
يقيم اه في هذا ال في هذا ال ال ال ال ال
ال المكان
المباني المجاوره وتم محاصره مبنى القصر
الذي يتواجد في داخله دوله رئيس الوزراء
احب ان اؤكد هنا ان هذا الخبر صحه هذا
الخبر واكد انه اذا استمر هذا الوضع اه ان
اه ان اه ان هذا الوضع قد ينتج يترتب عن
المعطيات جديده قد لا يتوقعها الكثيرون من
من المراقبين ولا من القوه السياسيه
اليمنيه خلال الساعات القادمه اذا استمر
هذا الوضع وهذا الحصار على
وما هو نتوقع سيد خالد
اه
اه هذه رساله اوجهها
لكل اه من يحاول ان ينفذ اليمن اه ومن من
لازالت لديه حرص على القاده اليمن شعبا
وتاريخ مما حدث اليوم لليوم الاسود
طيب الحوثيون يقول بانكم انتم او الجهات
الرسميه هي من انقلبت وليس ما يقومون به
الان ما الذي يجري الان هل اليمن يتجه
باتجاه انقلاب في البلد
سيدي الكريم نحن كحكومه كفاءات القوى
السياسيه الموقعه على اتفاق المشتركه بما
فيها القوه انصار الله الحوثيين وقعوا بعد
هذه الاتفاق على اتفاقيه تطوير ودعم الاخ
رئيس الجمهوريه ورئيس الوزراء ان يدعموا
هذه الحكومه وان لا يعترضون عليها هذا
بالنسبه فيما يتعلق بموقف حكومه
الارتفاعات حكومه القضاء تولت المسؤوليه
في التاريخ صعب شخصيات غامرت في تاريخه
السياسي في سمعتها لانقاذ بلد
اوصله
القوى السياسيه اه م ما كانت هذه القوى
السياسيه الى هذا الوضع اتفق الجميع ان
تاتي حكومه قطاعات تتولى دوله رئيس
الوزراء سياسه الت هذه الحكومه لكي ما
نقوم به فقط هي مهمه انقاذ ينقد البلد من
هذا الوضع الذي وصلت اليه يسير البلد الى
انتخابات اسطولها اي طرف يفوز فيها من
المنفذ لكن يبدو ان هناك حكومه الانقاذ
هذه انتم هذا البلد
ويحاول صنع المزيد من العراقيل والان ساعه
حاضر وماضي ومستقبل اليوم كيف تفسرون بلد
مثل اليمن يقع تحت مسؤوليه الامم المتحده
في وضعه الحالي بدايه من المبادره
الخليجيه وانتهاءا بقرارات مجلس الامن ومع
ذلك يحدث فيه ما يحدث ولا فعل يعني اه
ظاهر من قبل المجتمع الدولي وتحديدا من
قبل مجلس الامن
اه اه حقيقه هذا ما يثير فعلا اه استمرار
الكبير لكن في نفس الوقت انا اؤكد اه
واشير هنا بموقف الاشقاء في مجلس التعاون
الخليجي ال الاشكال بن دائما نجدهم في اه
اه بجوارنا في كل الملمات وفي كل المصاعب
اه وانا متاكد واؤكد هنا لليمنيين ان
الاشقاء في الخليج لم
على اليمن ولم يرفعوا ايديهم
ولم يكونوا الا اه الا داعي الخير لامن
واستقرار اه
وسلامه اليمن اه اما المجتمع الدولي ان
يتحمل مسؤوليته
اليوم 2011 دخل في مبادره خليجيه رعتها
عشر دول بما فيها الدول الدائمه العضويه
ال ان تتحمل مسؤوليه تاريخيه ومسؤوليه
اخلاقيه اتجاه ما يحدث في اليمن رغم
تقديرنا لكل الجهود التي قاموا بها
والجهود التي يبذلها الامين العام للامم
المتحده سيد جمال اه بالعمر اشكرك سيدي
الناطق باسم رئيس الحكومه كنت معنا من
العاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء ضيفي من بيروت سيد
عبد الحافظ مع فيما يتعلق بما ذكرناه عن
وقوع اليمن تحت مسؤوليه و طائله بنود في
مجلس الامن والبند السابع في مجلس الامن
هل يراعى الحوثيون هذه المساله وهم يقومون
ما يقومون به اليه
انا وضحت لك سابقا انه اه التحرك اليوم هو
تحرك للجان الشعبيه واللجان الثوريه
والحوثيين هم جزء من هذه اللجان اما
بالنسبه للوصايه الخارجيه ككل ومشروع
البند السابع وقرارات مجلس الامن فهي غير
ملزمه لليمنيين اه بشكل عام اه غير اه غير
ملزمه تماما واليمنيين لا يابهون بها
اليوم ما يحدث في الشارع اليمني هي تلك
الشرعيه الثوريه التي اسقطت زين العابدين
بن علي تلك الشرعيه الثوريه التي اخذت
مبارك الى السجن وتلك الشرعيه الثوريه
التي اسقطت علي عبد الله صالح هي ذاتها
الشرعيه الثوريه اليوم التي تتحرك بها
اللجان الثوريه واللجان الشعبيه اه ل اه
اه اه استكمال الثوره الشعبيه السلميه
المصالح الحوثيين الى نفس الشرعيه
علي عبد الله صالح لم ولن يكون حليفا
للثوار ابدا يعني عبد الله صالح من يحميه
اليوم هي الاتفاقيات التي خرجت بها مخرجات
مؤتمر الحوار الوطني واذا لم يتم تنفيذها
والى اذا لم يلتزم علي عبد الله صالح ما
خرج به مؤتمر الحوار الوطني سيكون مصيره
المحاكمه وسيكون مصير السجن وهذا امر
طبيعي جدا يدركه علي عبد الله صالح الذي
يحاول اليوم ان يناور وان يدعي بان له
علاقه بما يحدث اما ما يحدث ميدانيا فانا
اؤكد لكم ان النظام علي عبد الله صالح
الذي ذهب غير رجعه لن يعود لن يعود ولا
يمكن ان يكون هناك اي يعني عبد الله صالح
او اسره فيما يحدث هناك موعد وقيادات
للمؤتمر الشعبيه العام انخرطت في الحلقه
الثوريه وهذا من حقها باعتبارها جزء من
الشعب اليمني المؤتمر الشعبي العام هو
مكون سياسي سواء كان فيه علي عبد الله
صالح عبدربه منصور هادي هم جزء من هذا
الشعب
اسئله
الحالي
يا سيدي يا سيدي عن اي مشهد مقبل اليمن
اليمن المقبل اذا ما استمرت الامور على ما
هي عليه دون تدخل المجتمع الدولي الذي يقع
الامام في عودته والذي يقف صامتا بشكل
مريب ازاء هذه الاحداث اليمن المقبل الى
مزيد من التمزق والفوضى والحرب الطائفيه
الاخوان انا هنا الذي في بيروت الذي يسمى
اللجان الثوريه معقوله انهم لجان مناطقيه
طائفيه ويقولون البلاد الى الهاويه يريدون
تجزئه اليمن اه اه على اساس طائفي
هذا هو توجههم هؤلاء الناس لا يمثلون
اراده الشعب اليمني ابدا ثوره فبراير كان
تمثل اراده الشعب اليمني ولازال تمثل
اراده الشعب اليمني كانت تطمح الى دوله
الوطنيه دوله للعيش المشترك هؤلاء
يريدونها دوله طائفيه في اعتقادي ان
الحوثيون بهذه الاعمال استهدف الدستور
بشكل اساسي استهدف احداث حاله قطع معك
التزامات ال الماضي مع الاتفاقيات التي
تحكم عمليه التسويه ايجاد وضع جديد مختلف
تماما ان يكون في حل من امرهم
ما يتم تسريبه الان من الحديث عن مجلس
عسكري حتى وضعت بعض الاسماء عن الحادث
هناك تململ في وسط جنرالات داخل الجيش من
عدم قدره الرئيس هادي في وقوته في في
السيطره على الوضع هل هذا
بسيناريو مقبلا وبتصور مقبل للساعات وربما
الايام القادمه في اليمن
بالتاكيد حتى الحديث عن المجلس العسكري
قادم لن لن يغير من الامر شيء سيكون دنيا
كما هو حال الرئيس الحالي ما حدث هو ان
الوحدات العسكريه التي ترابط في العاصمه
صنعاء للاسف الشديد هذه الصفه مناطقيا و
طائفيا مع مشروع اجهاض الدوله هذا الذي
حدث لكن لازال في الجيش وحدات عسكريه قويه
ومتماسكه ومنتشره في جميع انحاء اليمن خطا
هذه انه يعني دور القوات المسلحه والجيش
الوطني الذي كان يؤمن حاله من التوازن وما
كان لهؤلاء ان ينجز كلما ينجزه اليوم لو
كانت الوحدات العسكريه الذي عمل على
تصفيتها وتشتيتها وتتيح موجوده في اعتقادي
ان المساله مفتوحه على كل الاحتمالات
لكنها احتمالات السيئه في غالب الاحوال
هناك توجه لتكريس البعد الطائفي ال بعض
المناطق في مستقبل اليمن الاتي وبالتالي
هو مستقبل اسود للاسف الشديد وهذا ال
المستقبل اشكر ولعلي اسنه الرماح
التي على اكتاف الميليشيات ال الم فتره
القادمه من صعده ومن المجمعات القبليه
المحافظه صناعه باسطنبول المحلل السياسي
سياسيه التميميه شكرا جزيلا لك كما اشكر
ضيفي من بيروت الناشط السياسي اليمني عبد
الحافظ معجب شكرا لضيفي وكذلك من كان معنا
كانوا معنا ضيوفي في هذه الحلقه
اذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد الى اللقاء
ام